bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat poursuivre l'audition
de jean claude ameisen jean claude
ameisen et médecins il et immunologiste
il est aussi membre du conseil
consultatif national d'éthique depuis
il en est le président depuis 2012
l'objet la mission de ce comité
consultatif d'éthique et bien c'est
d'émettre des avis sur des problèmes de
société sur des questions d'éthique
soulevées par les progrès de la science
et de la médecine
lors de cette audition jean claude
ameisen candidat à sa reconduction à la
tête du comité national consultatif
d'éthique a notamment exprimé son point
de vue sur la fin de vie sur
l'euthanasie il ya eu des questions sur
ce sujet mais aussi sur la procréation
médicalement assistée et notamment cette
procréation médicalement assistée pour
les couples homosexuels
une mesure qui était dans le programme
de françois hollande alors candidat à la
présidentielle mais qui a été sorti du
projet de loi sur le mariage pour tous
tout de suite donc retour à cette
audition de jean claude ameisen une
édition datant de début décembre
donc nous nous réunissons cet après midi
dans cette salle en application de
l'article 13 de la constitution pour
nous prononcer sur la nomination de
monsieur jean claude ameisen à la
présidence du ccee le comité consultatif
national d'éthique pour les sciences de
la vie et de la santé
après avoir procédé à son audition
publique
vous connaissez tous évidemment le rôle
du ccn eux qui permet par ses avis
d'éclairer l'opinion publique et les
autorités politiques sur les questions
d'ordre éthique soulevées par les
progrès de la biologie et de la médecine
le professeur jean claude ameisen a
présidé pendant dix ans le comité
d'éthique de l'inserm et sièges
puis 2005 au cce dont il est président
depuis 2012 est donc proposé de le
reconduire dans ses fonctions
je vais immédiatement lui céder la
parole afin qu'ils évoquent le bilan
d'activités ccn de haut durant ses deux
années de présidence et les perspectives
qui entrevoit pour les années à venir
à la fin de son audition on le mettra à
la porte
et puis nous pousse raison au vote
en même temps d'ailleurs que
s'effectuera le vote à l'assemblée
nationale mais je vous ai fait ensuite
les conditions dans lesquelles tout ça
doit se faire mais sur professeur
monsieur le président nous vous passons
bien volontiers la parole
merci beaucoup bonjour quelques mots
peut-être sur sur la démarche éthique
puisque vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup
d'approchés de et de représentation de
ce qu'est la démarche éthique pour moi
peut-être en raisonnement de mon
parcours et de mon histoire là
la démarche éthique est très proche de
la démarche de recherche
la démarche de recherche en sciences et
une démarche à la fois de respect pour
l'ensemble du savoir et des
connaissances accumulées et en même
temps une démarche de transgression qui
fait le pari que remettre en cause les
connaissances actuelles est le meilleur
moyen les questionner le meilleur moyen
de parvenir peut-être à des
connaissances nouvelles demain et donc
je trouve qu'il ya entre la recherche
scientifique et le savoir une relation
qui est assez proche de celle qu'il ya
entre la démarche éthique et la
déontologie les lois les les pratiques
et que donc la démarche éthique est à la
fois une démarche de respect pour
l'ensemble des solutions qui a été
trouvé
pour pouvoir mettre en relation les
pratiques et les et les valeurs et en
même temps une démarche de
questionnement qui vise à explorer
l'inconnu pour essayer de trouver des
réponses éventuellement plus
satisfaisante ou plus souhaitable la
deuxième relation je dirais entre la
recherche et la démarche éthique tient
au fait que la démarche scientifique en
effaçant les frontières entre la matière
inanimée le vivant entre les cellules et
corps entre l'animal et l'humain entre
le corps et l'esprit à quelque chose qui
à la fois et merveilleux mais qui peut
donner l'impression d'une d'une démarche
de déshumanisation d'une démarche de
réification surtout lorsque ce qu'elle
observe et cas l'étudié qu'elle manipule
comme objet vu de l'extérieur nous
concerne directement parce que ça
concerne le vivant parce que ça concerne
des parties de nous-mêmes ou parce que
ça nous concerne et c'est ce que ce
qu'évoquait martin buber dans un très
beau livre jeu et tu y as 80 en disant
que la science lorsqu'elle parle de nous
dit il ou elle ou ceci ou cela et que
nous nous vivons comme des jeux qui
disent tu qu'on attende quiconque on
attend des autres qui nous disent tu es
que nous construisons un nous est donc
l'enjeu éthique 10 et il était de
réussir à mettre ce que nous apprenons
de la science en tant qu sur nous en
tant qu' il elle ceci ou cela au service
du jeu du tu es dunes ou et il ya je
crois 2 2 deux grands principes de la
démarche éthique biomédicale modernes
qui sont fondés sur cette vision la
première est l'un des piliers depuis
soixante dix ans pile connu rabais en
1947 de la démarche éthique du médical
moderne qui est ce qu'on appelait le
consentement libre et informé qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le choix libre et
informé qu'ils implicitement définit une
hiérarchie entre la connaissance et
l'autonomie à la liberté c'est à dire
que la connaissance dans le don le côté
informé du choix libre et informé
la connaissance est mise à la
disposition de la personne pour que la
personne puisse élaborer librement son
choix
ça n'est pas la personne qui est
instrumentalisée de part la connaissance
qu'on a acquis sur elle par une démarche
scientifique
la deuxième application c'est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui un comité comme le comité
consultatif national d'éthique n'est
considérez les comme légitimes dont le
monde que si les indépendants et que si
il ne comporte pas que des experts en
biologie et en médecine l'expertisé
nécessaire mais elle est considérée
comme insuffisante et donc un comité qui
ne sera constitué que de biologistes et
deux médecins seraient considérées comme
illégitimes quand les questions qui se
pose c'est celle du meilleur moyen de
mettre les connaissances scientifiques
en biologie et en médecine au service du
respect de la personne et donc il ya
cette idée de croiser les regards et
d'élaborer une réflexion qui dépasse qui
inclut mais qui dépasse les expertises
et ma conviction profonde en ce qui
concerne le comité consultatif national
d'éthique et que sa mission essentielle
en tout cas mes yeux est de favoriser la
réflexion et l'élaboration individuel et
collectif d'une forme de choix libre et
informé et non pas de se substituer à la
réflexion et au choix de la société
quelques mots sur le comité consultatif
national d'éthique que vous connaissez
c'est le premier comité de ce tube créé
au monde
il a été créé il ya 31 ans ya maintenant
des comités consultatifs mais sur nos
des tic dans tous les pays européens et
dans la plupart des pays du monde
quarante membres une minorité de
biologistes et de médecins et des
philosophes des juristes des
anthropologues des sociologues
quarante membres nommés par une
quinzaine d'institutions ce qui assure à
priori une diversité de parcours et de
points de vue
une mission élaborer des avis depuis 31
ans vit depuis 30 ans depuis la vie
numéro un le comité a élaboré 122 avis
alors avis auquel le législateur nous a
dit que nous pouvons adjoindre si nous
le jugeons utile des recommandations je
reviens ce que je disais il semble que
la mission essentielle c'est d'aider à
la réflexion et on peut éventuellement
lorsque ça semble indispensable
nécessaire
il ya toujours un des recommandations
mais c'est vrai que dans la société
souvent l'idée c'est que le comité
recommande d'une certaine façon se
substitue à la la la réflexion éthique
de la société
deuxième mission animer la réflexion est
donc il ya une journée public qui est
qui est conçue par le le lit cette heure
et ce dans cette journée nous la
consacrons depuis deux ans à des travaux
de lycéens
une douzaine de lycées en partenariat
avec le ccn qui pendant l'année sur la
base du volontariat avec leur professeur
de philosophie et de sciences de la vie
et de la terre réfléchissent à une
question éthique viennent la présenter
en public discute avec les membres du
cce et discutent avec le public et donc
je pense que c'est intéressant là encore
2 j'espère que cette initiative pourrait
être étendue au-delà de cette douzaine
de deux lycées partenaires parce que je
pense que c'est important que
l'appropriation d'une réflexion éthique
commence relativement tôt si on veut
véritablement qu'elles vivent dans la
société et depuis la loi du 7 juillet
2011 relative à la bioéthique le
législateur a confié une autre mission
au ccn je dirais quirky qui qui rajoute
à cette notion d'animation du débat
public c'est que en cas de projet de
réforme en cas de au cas où un projet
doit être envisagée le comité doit
initier l'organisation d'un débat public
sous la forme d' états généraux
comportant des conférences de citoyens
durant ces deux dernières années nous
avons rendu quatre avis et nous avons
été particulièrement occupé par les
questions qui concernent la fin de vie
et nous sommes entrés dans des activités
je vais vous les décrire brièvement
inhabituel et nouvelle pour le ccn donc
à partir du moment où en juillet 2012 le
président de la république a nommé la
commission sicard la commission de
réflexion sur la fin de vie il a annoncé
qu'une fois que la commission lui
remettra son rapport il saisirait le ccn
eux ce qui l'a fait au début de l'année
2013 et donc nous avons rendu un avis la
vie 121 sur les questions éthiques liées
à la fin de vie étant donné qu'il y
avait eu annonce du dépôt d'un projet de
loi
nous avons dans cet avis recommandez
proposé la tenue d'un débat public et
l'organisation d'une conférence de
citoyens nous avons donc organisé une
conférence de citoyens qui a donc je
pourrais vous parler si vous le
souhaitez qui a rendu son avis en
décembre 2013
et pour donner à ces débats a une
envergure plus proche des états généraux
la commission sicard avait déjà nous en
avons bénéficié organiser des débats
citoyens dans nos vies de france et donc
nous sommes allés voir les les
responsables de tous les espaces
régionaux de réflexion éthique qui ont
été créés formellement il ya deux ans et
dont une des missions est d'animer les
débats publics sur les questions
d'éthique biomédicale dans leur région
en leur demandant s'ils le souhaitaient
d'animer des débats autour de cette
question de la fin de vie oui à prendre
et donc c'est ce qu'ils ont fait et huit
de ces espaces région de réflexion
éthique nous ont renvoyé les comptes
rendus de ces débats que nous avons mis
en ligne
une fois que nous avons donc
l'organisation de cette conférence de
citoyens étaient quelque chose de
totalement nouveau très inhabituel est
extrêmement intéressant pour le comité
consultatif national d'éthique
nous avons ensuite été impliqué dans une
autre démarche nouvelle et inhabituelle
lorsque le conseil d'état statuant sur
le cas de monsieur vincent lambert a
demandé au ccnr au conseil national de
l'ordre des médecins à l'académie
nationale de médecine et à jean leonetti
de lui fournir des observations écrites
d'ordre général susceptibles de
l'éclairer sur les notions d'obstination
déraisonnable et de maintien artificiel
en vie pour des personnes qui comme
monsieur vincent lambert sont dans un
état dit possi relationnel c'est à dire
de conscience minimale et donc ça nous a
amenés à réfléchir à la fois aux
questions éthiques et à l'interprétation
de la loi du 22 avril 2005 à propos de
deux situations tout à fait extrême de
conscience minimale et puis ensuite
comme nous le demande la la le
législateur dans la loi du 7 juillet
2011 relative à la bioéthique
nous avons élaboré un rapport sur
l'ensemble du débat public c'est à dire
sur ce qu'il y avait eu en terme de
débats publics depuis la création de la
commission sicard rapport que nous avons
rendu tout récemment durant le mois
d'octobre donc cesser je dirais que là
la réflexion à propos de la fin de vie
sur les questions éthiques posés par la
fin de vie nous a amenés non seulement à
réfléchir de manière approfondie et
successives
je dirais à mesurer la complexité des
enjeux à mesure que nous progressions
dans notre réflexion mais aussi de le
faire dans un cadre et dans un contexte
et dans des activités qui jusqu'à
maintenant n'a vait pas été celle du ccn
eux
en dehors de ça je vous ai dit nous
avons produit quatre avis donc un sur la
fin de vie
l'autre était sur les questions éthiques
posés par c'était une saisine du
ministère de la ministre de la santé
posés par l'éventuelle mise sur le
marché de tests de diagnostic rapide de
l'infection par le vih que les personnes
peuvent réaliser elle même le deuxième
c'était une saisine de du directeur
général de la santé c'étaient les
questions éthiques posés par le
séquençage complet de l'adn chez un
foetus âgé de huit semaines à partir
d'une goutte de sang prélevée chez la
femme enceinte donc qui pose toute une
série de deux questions nouvelles et le
troisième liste at her nous avait confié
là encore en 2011 une mission de veille
sur les neurosciences sur les questions
éthiques posés par une conscience et
nous avons donc produit un avis sur les
questions éthiques liées à ce que nous
avons intitulé entre guillemets la neuro
amélioration ce que les anglo-saxons
appellent niaux en semaine un terme très
ambigu qui peut être traduit à la fois
par neuro augmentation et neuro
améliorations comme si forcément toute
amélioration provenait d'une
augmentation des capacités les sujets
sur lesquels nous sommes en train de
travailler actuellement de manière très
brièvement
l'un nous nous étions saisi ya un an et
demi des questions relatives à
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
est plutôt que de les traiter une par
une de la manière dont ces questions se
posent maintenant insémination chez des
couples de femmes cryopréservation des
ovocytes pour une fécondation in vitro
ou ultérieur gestation pour autrui
anonymat pour les donneurs de vos sites
et de spermatozoïdes nous avons décidé
de réfléchir d'une manière transversale
aux questions éthiques pause assistance
médicale à la procréation dans l'espoir
de pouvoir ensuite décliné cette grille
d'interprétation aux différentes
situations pour ne pas réfléchir à ces
situations en ordre dispersé et
éventuellement de manière contradictoire
donc d'appliquer un peu la même démarche
que nous avons eues en ce qui concerne
la fin de vie le deuxième sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons c'est
l'extension de la question du séquençage
de l'adn chez le foetus âgé de huit
semaines
c'est toutes les questions éthiques
liées au séquençage complet de l'adn à
tous les âges de la vie
et puis la troisième question qui est
une question inhabituelle pour le un peu
inhabituel pour le ccn eux mais qui
progresse est une question qui concerne
ce une autosaisine les questions
éthiques posés par les atteintes à la
biodiversité et les changements
climatiques est donc juste à ce propos
on a souvent l'impression et c'est vrai
que les questions d'éthique biomédicale
portent essentiellement sur le tout
début de la vie l'embryon l'assistance
médicale à la procréation
l'hérédité et la génétique et la toute
fin de vie
mais le cce a par le passé aborder les
questions qui sortent de ce champ par
exemple il ya eu un avis sur santé et
médecine en prison il ya eu un avis sur
angers éthique des nanosciences et des
nanotechnologies a eu un avis sur angers
ticket implications éthiques de la
biométrie dans les papiers d'identité
donc le le cce et seuil je dirais de 2,2
d'embrasser de réfléchir aux questions
qui touchent l'éthique biomédicale
qu'ils s'agissent d'avancées récentes de
la biologie de la médecine ou qu'ils
s'agissent d'avancer un peu plus ancien
mais qui poserait des problèmes et des
questions éthiques contemporaine un mot
peut-être sur nos activités
internationales
il y à tous les deux ans le dernier
était en juin à mexico il y à tous les
deux ans une réunion de l'ensemble des
comités d'éthique dans le monde
il y a une à deux fois par an le dernier
thé ya deux semaines à rome une réunion
de tous les comités d'éthique de la
communauté européenne et il y a
traditionnellement à cause d'eux
deux raisons historiques des réunions
deux fois par an entre le comité
français le comité allemand et le comité
anglais et donc ces réunions sur
extrêmement utile parce que je vous ai
parlé de regards croisés à l'intérieur
du comité mais lorsque nous nous
réunissons entre comité de pays
différents que ce soit en europe ou plus
forte raison quand il s'agit du monde
eh bien ces regards croisés sont pas
seulement des yachts des regards croisés
de personnes dont les parcours ou les
professions sont différentes mais deux
personnes qui habitent des pays dont
l'histoire la culture est différente et
donc ça nous horrifie énormément et en
général ce que nous percevons céder ce
qui nous apparaît comme des points
aveugles dans les raisonnements de nos
collègues et nos collègues nous font
ressortir que certains de nos
raisonnements et certaines de leurs
réflexions comporte des points aveugles
sur lesquels il est bon ensuite de
pouvoir revenir et de pouvoir nous
réinterroger un mot peut-être sur un
certain nombre de 2 2 d'avancé que que
je souhaiterais que nous souhaiterions
mené la première concerne cette
dimension internationale avec peut-être
deux objectifs l'un sait on parle
beaucoup dans les débats d'éthique
biomédicale dans notre pays on parle
beaucoup des autres de ce qui se fait
dans d'autres pays y compris dans
d'autres pays européens mais on écoute
assez rarement les autres nous parler de
ce qu'ils pensent de ce qui s'y fait
donc faire en sorte que les débats les
débats publics et réflexion puisse
comporter nos homologues des comités
d'éthique d'autres pays pour faciliter
la réflexion dans dans dans notre pays
le deuxième c'est la disparité des
législations dans les différents pays
européens et vous savez que ça pose des
problèmes et récemment encore au niveau
juridique en ce qui concerne la
gestation pour autrui et le statut des
enfants nés
par gestation pour autrui avec la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
veille au respect des droits de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme est donc une des questions c'est
comment mener une réflexion éthique
je dirais qu'il prend en compte à la
fois la disparité des législations dans
les différents pays européens
la libre circulation des citoyens à
travers l'europe et le fait que la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et la
cour européenne de justice juge du
caractère du respect des droits
fondamentaux des personnes dans des
législations qui sont très différentes
et parfois même contradictoires et donc
nous allons demander à nos homologues
il ya trois semaines lors d'une réunion
que nous avions avec eux anglais et
allemands de réfléchir avec nous de
commencer à réfléchir avec nous à aa une
à la réflexion éthique que l'on peut
avoir par rapport à à à ces problèmes
complexes et je pense que ça deviendra
ça devrait devenir un des sujets du
premier sommet mondial du prochain
sommet mondial qui aura lieu dans dans
un an et demi à berlin troisième point
je vous ai parlé de ce sujet que nous
traitons actuellement qui est
biodiversité questions éthiques et allez
me dire c'était au climat nous pensons
que c'est une réflexion qui ne peut pas
être une réflexion purement française
parce que les enjeux sont mondiaux et
internationaux et donc nous voulons
avant la conférence climat qui aura lieu
en décembre 2015
organiser un symposium avec nos
homologues de comités d'éthique de pays
étrangers en particulier de l'hémisphère
sud pour réfléchir ensemble au moment où
nous essayons d'élaborer un avis aux
questions éthiques
avec ces regards croisés internationaux
qui se posent en matière de biodiversité
et le pari la question c'est est-ce
qu'une réflexion éthique sur ce sujet
apporter quelque chose par rapport aux
réflexions d'experts qui sont déjà
abondantes dans ce domaine le deuxième
point c'est l'organisation du débat
public je vous disais essayer d'y
introduire un regard international mais
aussi essayer de faire en sorte que le
comité consultatif national d'éthique ne
se retrouvent pas opérateurs de
l'organisation de tous les débats
publics
parce que si nous devenons opérateurs
d'organisation de débat public nous
cesserons de pouvoir assurer nos autres
missions donc l'utilisateur très très
très sagement demandé au comité
d'initiés l'organisation d'états
généraux et donc nous sommes en
réflexion et discussion en particulier
avec la commission nationale du débat
public pour voir si d'autres
institutions dont le rôle est d'animer
dans d'autres domaines
la réflexion et le débat public peuvent
nous aider à animer une réflexion dans
ce domaine troisième point je vous ai
parlé de cette initiative ancien du cce
ne d'animation de la réflexion éthique
chez les lycéens
nous souhaitons l'étendre aux étudiants
et donc favorisées pour des étudiants
dans des universités la réflexion
éthique et donc on on vient de mettre en
place un partenariat avec l'école
normale supérieure pour commencer
et ça se fera sous forme de symposium
organisé par des étudiants des
différentes disciplines sciences dures
sciences humaines et sociales les
enseignants et des membres du cce pour
essayer sur un certain nombre de sujets
transversaux encore une fois de voir
comment on peut passer de l'animation de
la réflexion éthique au niveau lycée à
une animation de la réflexion éthique ou
à l'émergence à la facilitation
d'émergence de réflexion éthique dans le
monde des étudiants voilà merci
voilà mes chers collègues je pense qu'il
y a évidemment beaucoup de questions le
premier cas levé la main c'est monsieur
code francs sur les enjeux et ça ça ne
vous surprendra pas il y as en 2012
quand vous étiez venu devons-nous
monsieur le professeur
je vous avais posé trois questions je
vous avais demandé quel était votre
votre schéma de travail sur la fin de
vie
la procréation médicalement assistée la
gpa vous venez en partie d'y répondre
et donc aujourd'hui qu'en est il je
considère que sur sur la fin de vie
le conseil consultatif national
d'éthique a rempli parfaitement son rôle
pour informer et décideurs que nous
sommes de ce que nous vous devons mettre
dans une éventuelle loi
vous avez donc rappelé la vie sont 21
vous avez rappelé la vie que vous venez
de rome de remettre au mois d'octobre
est un peu différent beaucoup pas
beaucoup un peu différent il pas vrai ce
n'est pas un avis et un rapport une
activité nouvelle du ccn c'est à dire au
fond c'est la lecture par le ccn
2 ce qui s'est dit ou deux ce qui de
ceux dont nous pensons que ça ne s'est
pas dit mais que c'est aussi interprété
au cours du débat public un rapport
c'était la vie c'était 521 et vous allez
organiser ce débat public avec une
conférence citoyenne qui a fait valoir
un certain nombre de dispositions
qu'elle est peut-être beaucoup plus loin
que ce que certains auraient pu imaginer
notamment sur la fin de vie sur la
possibilité d'accès à un acte médical
pour abréger l'existence est également
sur le suicide assisté
donc les avis que vous avez rendu
l'arrêt le rappeur je pense nous
permettent d'être parfaitement éclairé
il appartient maintenant au législateur
ou au gouvernement de s'en saisir pour
déposer ou pas un texte de loi qui
considère que vous avez le cl
parfaitement rempli de son son travail
en la matière concernant l'assistance
médicalisée à propres opérations
pourriez-vous nous dire dans quel délai
vous envisagez de pouvoir remettre j'ai
pas ici un avis ou un rapport mais il
est évident que depuis 2012 il ya eu des
évolutions la loi taubira et donc la
perspective que l'on peut avoir sur la
procréation médicalement assistée voir
la gpa peut-être différente de l'époque
ensuite concernant la gestation pour
autrui même s'il a été déclarée par
beaucoup de personnes que le débat n'ait
pas lieu d'être
force est de constater qu'il s'impose à
nous puisque c'est qu'elle a fait qui
existe et je pense que nous avons une
loi une proposition de loi déposée par
monsieur leonetti qui doit passer à
l'assemblée nationale dans peu de temps
tu qui est une proposition de loi qui
est purement répressive et qui n'ouvre
pas le débat sur la gpa donc je devrais
savoir quand est ce que vous pouvez
imaginer de remettre un avis du cn sur
ce sur ce problème
il serait peut-être urgent d'attendre
avant de légiférer que vous ayez
formuler un avis
je voudrais vous dire aussi que je
partage totalement votre sentiment sur
la dimension internationale parce qu'il
il est vrai pour les problèmes d'éthique
comme beaucoup d'autres problèmes
sociétaux la libre circulation des
individus fait que nous devons tenir
compte de l'environnement international
que nous pouvons pas prétendre légiférer
tout seul sans tenir compte des
incidences que d'autres pays l'agitation
d'autres pays peuvent peuvent avoir et
je partage parfaitement également votre
avis
sur le fait que le conseil consultatif
national d'éthique ne peut pas être le
lieu du débat public sur tous les sujets
il risquerait de perdre sa fonction donc
en conséquence et en ouverture je
considère attend qu'un petit peu anciens
comme doute ici que ce que nous avions
demandé le conseil consultatif national
d'éthique a parfaitement rempli le rôle
que nous l'avions assigné les demandes
et bien donc après avoir donné la parole
à un ancien va donner la parole à une
jeune le modem dano merci monsieur le
président mais c'est le président du
comité consultatif national d'éthique
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire une
observation plus des remerciements parce
que les questions que j'avais préparé
pour cette rencontre a été justement
basé sur après deux ans de présidence
quel était votre bilan et vous l'avez
tout à fait tracer et puis je voulais
vous demander quelles sont les
perspectives
moi je pensais que effectivement le
comité souffrait d'un certain manque de
visibilité dans le grand public
en fait est clairement vous avez
exprimée à travers vos propos le fait
que vous vous étiez intéressé à des
questions d'actualité qui ont été
d'ailleurs apporté par mon collègue et
que donc ça vous ouvrait des
perspectives pour être mieux connu et
puis l'indication sur ces animations que
vous faites auprès des jeunes me paraît
tout à fait aussi essentiel pour
justement pas vulgariser mais en tout
cas vraiment mieux faire connaître votre
avoue est juste une petite question
parce que pendant le
l'examen du plfss nous avons une
question qui a été débattue au sein de
notre commission c'était par rapport au
don du sang et il est question de
médecine et des questions d'éthique
en fait le don du sang doit d'être
gratuit quand on parle de dont on
pourrait penser que oui en même temps
c'est que dans d'autres pays
voilà c'est quelque chose ce qui est
rémunérée et puis il ya ces produits de
substitution au sang qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous qu'il y avait cette vue
national voire international
donc merci de vos réponses bien mais
pour l'instant nous vous écoutons ce
professeur alors sur la sur la question
de l'assistance médicale à la
procréation alors en sur la question de
la gestation pour autrui le comité avait
rendu un avis il ya quatre ans mais
comme vous dites nous nous revenons nous
nous nous nous examinons l'ensemble des
questions liées à l'assistance médicale
à la procréation et donc la gestation
pour autrui en fait partie je pense
c'est ce que j'avais annoncé que cet
avis ne sera pas rendu public
il avance avant le printemps la fin du
printemps le début de l'été de l'année
2015 pour l'instant est en est qu'il
n'ya pas une annonce de de dépôt d'un
projet de loi
nous n'avons pas engagé lalala
l'organisation d'une conférence de
citoyens et des états généraux mais je
dire donc nous travaillons comme si
c'était un avis habituel et donc je
pense que ça sera ça sera le printemps
2015 en ce qui concerne le don du sang
votre question sur le don du sang alors
je peux vous donner mon ma vision
personnelle je pense que c'est un sujet
que le comité va revoir pour le deuxième
aspect de la question vous posiez qui
sont les laits produits et leur libre
circulation y compris lorsqu'il s'agit
de produits industriels vont du est
commercialisé avec la libre circulation
à travers l'europe dont je crois que
c'est une question que le comité va
peut-être prendre
mais sur le don de la gratuité du don du
sang à titre personnel je pense que
s'ils voulaient le don du sang
contrairement à d'autres dons est un don
fond qui ne présentent pas de risque
pour les personnes c'est pas comme un
don d'ovocytes c'est pas commun à un don
de rein et donc c'est quelque chose qui
dans beaucoup de pays pour attirer un
plus grand nombre de donneurs eh bien on
m'a dit on va les payer
je crois que le cette idée de la
gratuité du don qui est un pléonasme
comme vous le disiez cesser les dons
rémunéré c'est pas des dons on achète
tous les jours des dons qu'on qu'on paye
donc je crois qu'il faut aussi garder le
sens des mots font un don c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est gratuit et je
crois que fonder le notre système de
santé sur la gratuité des produits
biologiques qui sont mis à disposition
de ceux qui souffrent à un aspect
éthique important qui est que si on paye
pour du centre mais c'est vrai pour tous
les produits biologiques et bien la
probabilité est grande que ce sont ceux
qui sont les plus démunis qui sont les
plus pauvres qui vont donner et je crois
que base et un système de solidarité en
matière de santé sur la contribution de
ceux qui d'une certaine façon
paradoxalement en ont le plus besoin et
y ont le moins accès pour que d'autres
puissent avoir accès et quelque chose
qui pose un problème éthique et donc
pour moi c'est c'est pas de temps si
vous voulez le risque que du don du sang
il n'y a pas de risque quand le fait
raisonnablement qu'on le paye qu'on le
paye pas après les demandes sans ça ne
change rien mais je crois que ça fonde
une approche de la santé publique qui je
crois est est particulière et qui je
crois mérite considération réflexion par
rapport à d'autres pays et on voit que
ce qui est vrai pour le don du sang dans
beaucoup d'autres pays du monde est vrai
aussi pour le prélèvement d'ovocytes
puisque certains de nos voisins
européens
après les mots changent rémunère
indemnise
lorsqu'il y allons pas ton mais
lorsqu'il ya possibilité de mettre à
disposition des ovocytes et je crois que
c'est ça vraiment le problème il ya une
contradiction il est évident qu'une
incitation financière augmente le nombre
de contributeurs
mais créer une profonde asymétrie entre
ceux qui contribuent et ceux qui
reçoivent dans dans la société
d'autres questions madame david oui
merci monsieur président remercier le
professeur un mécène et remercié
également nos deux collègues parce que
c'est vrai que les questions étaient
intéressantes notamment sur le don du
sang c'est vrai que nous avons eu un
fort débat à la commission donc c'était
bien que nous puissions en reparler
aujourd'hui j'aurais peut-être deux
précisions à vous demandez vous nous
avez parlé monsieur le président de
possibilité d'auto saisine du comité
d'éthique donc par exemple vous avez dit
sans doute on va se saisir du don enfin
en tout cas de la deuxième partie de la
question de notre collègue sur les
produits de substitution
comment est ce que vous pouvez enfin
quelle est la procédure si j'emploie ce
terme d'autosaisine je l'imaginais un
peu mais ce que vous pouvez nous l'a
précisé comment faites-vous pour choisir
les sujets justement pour lesquelles le
comité consultatif national d'éthique
peut s'autosaisir vous avez sans doute
enfin vous avez aussi des demandes qui
vous sont transmises mais comment faites
vous pour vous auto saisir et sur quel
sujet puisque vous nous avez également
parlé dans votre introduction de de
votre démarche et du lien que vous voyez
entre ce comité d'éthique et la
recherche puisque vous nous avez parlé
d'une démarche de questionnement
donc est ce que là aussi vous pouvez
nous nous dira un petit peu comment se
les membres du comité se questionne pour
pouvoir aboutir à cette auto saisine ou
à d'autres sujets et je reviendrai juste
sur ce dont a parlé notre collègue jean
pierre godefroy sur ce qui a été ce que
vous avez organisé
des états généraux et la consultation
que vous avez menées avec l'avis rendu
la vie 121 vous vous en souvenez on
s'était rencontré à cette occasion aux
moments un peu avant de mettre en route
ces débats et j'avais été un peu comment
dire je trouve pas un mot comment qui ne
soit pas j'avais été un peu interpellé
on va dire sur le choix des
personnalités que vous aviez choisi pour
pour animer ces débats voilà donc
comment faites vous aussi pour le choix
des personnalités puisque dans cette
consultation des citoyens
c'est donc des femmes et des hommes qui
sont un petit peu choisis et qui
participent à ces ateliers et qui sont
en contact avec des spécialistes
comment faites vous pour avoir des
spécialistes je dirais non pas neutre
parce qu'un spécialiste n'est pas
forcément notamment tout cas qui qui a
un regard complet sur l'ensemble du du
dossier merci madame procas y sommes
merci à monsieur le président monsieur
médecine ce matin vos informations on
entendait qu'il y avait une une
nouvelles possibilités pour les dons
d'organes et en l'occurrence quand une
équipe médicale décide qu'elle va cesser
de faire de prodiguer des soins parce
que il n'y a plus du tout d'espoir
j'aimerais simplement savoir si pour ce
type d'extensions de dons d'organes
le comité a été associée et et comment
vous avez travaillé dans ces cas là pour
aboutir à ce qui est mis en place d'un
objet qu'ils sont merci monsieur le
professeur je partirai d2 et des
exemples que nos collègues ont évoqué le
don d'organes la différence de
l'initiation 3 législation française et
différents pays européens
le sujet de le sujet de la fin de vie et
savoir comment vous intégrer dans vos
travaux la disparité des législations
dans les différents pays et à votre
propre réflexion parce que on peut se
dire ah oui c'est bien pour par exemple
je pense au sujet de la fin de vie qui
fait à peu près enfin je vais pas dire
complètement mais peut-être à peu près
consensus entre nous on peut se dire bon
d'autres pays sont plus évolués
je pense à d'autres questions par
exemple dont dans le don de le don du
sang on peut on peut peut-être c'est de
recueillir de la position de la position
française
alors comment vous arrivez à consacrer à
vous intégrer et vous concilier les deux
des marchés
voilà ce que c'est
je vais reprendre dans leur auto saisine
est saisie d'un certain nombre
d'institutions le président de la
république les ministres vous dites donc
un certain nombre d'institutions
président de république l'assemblée par
l'intermédiaire de son président le
sénat les ministères les responsables
dans ces deux institutions de recherche
et diversiterre peuvent saisir
officiellement le comité consultatif
national d'éthique d'une question
en dehors de ça le comité s'autosaisit
et ils s'auto s'est dit à partir de deux
origines tout citoyen peut écrire toute
association toute profession toute
institution peut écrire ou cessé de lui
présenter un problème et lui demander de
s'auto saisir de cette question
à ce moment le cce examine si la
question d'abord lui paraît suffisamment
général nous ne traitons pas de cas
particulier et si la question nous
paraît suffisamment importante par
rapport aux autres questions que nous
devons traiter pour nous en auto saisir
et puis à une troisième forme d'auto
saisine qui est lorsque le comité lui
même considère qu'une question que
personne ne lui a posé est suffisamment
importante pour qui la traitent ce qui
donne en général le le cc ne vient que
le croisement des regards le fait qu'il
nous faut élaborer dès le départ un
langage commun une question biologiques
et médicales très pointues et très
complexe à comprendre pour une
philosophe pour un juriste pour une
autre pologne inversement une question
de droit est très difficile à
appréhender pour une biologiste ou pour
un médecin est donc la première étape
c'est déjà d'essayer de de parler un
langage commun
je dirais de rentrer dans une démarche
que qui pourrit coeur était celle de de
l'entrée en éthique qui est de se penser
soi même comme un autre d'essayer de de
se mettre à la place des autres
et une fois qu'on a élaboré ce langage
commun on essaye d'avancer dans une
réflexion qui quand elle réussit permet
de faire émerger une réflexion qui est
différente de celle que chacun au départ
avec donc nous confrontons pas des
points de vue déjà pré établis
nous essayons de faire émerger quelque
chose qui dépasse les points de vue
initiaux ce qui à mon sens d'ailleurs et
c'est pour ça qu'en quand je parle
d'animation biava public est quelque
chose qui manque beaucoup dans notre
pays house souvent le débat c'est la
confrontation d'opinions préétabli et
pions il faut choisir et c'est pas cette
habitude qui existe dans certains pays
de se mettre à plusieurs dans la
diversité pour essayer de voir si on
peut pas faire émerger faire naître une
réflexion ou une solution nouvelle donc
le le ceas alors le temps est important
pour le ccn de ce qui revient la
première question
nous travaillons bien quand nous
travaillons lentement parce qu'il ya ce
cette acclimatation cette humilité cette
écoute cette construction commune qui
prend du temps qui est un processus au
fond de transformation lorsque nous
sommes saisis avec un calendrier
souhaité nous sommes un peu plus
contraints alors même si nous dépassons
assez souvent le calendrier souhaité
nous essayons de rester dans ce
calendrier
lorsque nous nous auto saucisson c'est
vrai qu' un très grand confort et donc
nous pouvons avancer à la vitesse que
nous croyons être celle de du service
que nous pouvons rendre voilà la société
donc je pense que le temps et c'est vrai
que c'est ce qu'ils m'ont beaucoup dans
la vie actuelle le temps de la réflexion
c'est sans doute quelque chose de très
important et soit dit en passant je
pense que les deux ans et demi de temps
consacré au débat et à la réflexion sur
la fin de vie sous des formes très
diverses a sans doute eu un effet sur la
société qui a permis de mieux prendre en
compte les enjeux la complexité la la la
la ce questionnement que au tout début
donc qui qui choisit qui décide en
premier lieu il ya douze membres du
comité qui sont élus par les 40 membres
et qui constituent ce qu'on appelle la
section technique qui a un président qui
était lui aussi par la section technique
et cette section technique un peu comme
un bureau reçoit les demandes et les
traitent en premier lieu s'interroge
lorsqu'un membre lorsque des membres
souhaitent que le comité s'autosaisit
s'interroge et puis une fois que c'est
section technique a réfléchi elle
revient devant le comité plénier pour
voir ce que pensent l'ensemble des morts
et donc c'est comme ça que
collectivement nous décidons à la fois
des questions dont nous nous saisissons
et de la priorité que nous leur
accordons alors nous pouvons répondre
lorsque nous pensons que il n'y a pas
lieu d'élaborer un avis nous pouvons
répondre à ceux qui nous saisissent sous
forme d'une lettre nous nous expliquons
notre point de vue mais sans 100 ans
sans en faire un un avis alors la
conférence de citoyens conférence du
citoyen c'est intéressant pour nous ça a
été tout à fait intéressant parce que
tout à fait nouveau on a d'abord fait un
appel d'offres public avec un budget
limité en demandant des opérateurs on a
eu un certain nombre d'opérateurs on
avait posé une condition qui a surpris
beaucoup d'opérateurs l'un d'entre nous
avait dit que ce serait impossible ce
qui m'avait beaucoup surpris une des
conditions était que les citoyens ne
soit pas rémunéré et indemnisé mais que
simplement l'offre leurs frais soient
remboursés il semble que de plus en plus
de conférences de citoyens rémunère les
citoyens ce qui à notre sens n'a pas
vraiment beaucoup de sens puisque ce
sont des personnes qui décident
bénévolement de participer à la
réflexion publique au bénéfice de la
société donc c'était une des conditions
donc l'opérateur que nous avons retenu
était l'ifop l'ifop qui avait d'ailleurs
organisé les trois conférences de
citoyens qui avaient eu lieu
organisée par jean leonetti avant la
révision de la loi relative à la
bioéthique de 2011 une fois que cette
conférence de citoyens étaient réunis
alors les critères choisis il n'était
évidemment pas représentatif de la
population française il faut plus de
1000 personnes
mais il était choisi par l'ifop sur les
critères de l'insee c'est à dire
correspondant en termes d'âge de
profession de répartition géographique
d'habitation rurales ou urbaines à la
grille de l'ensemble de la nation donc
pas représentatif mais je veux dire
choisis sur des critères qui
correspondent à ceux de la nation
c'est très intéressant parce que ces 18
personnes se rencontrent pour la
première fois ne se connaissent pas nous
avons beaucoup réfléchi pour savoir si
nous voulions assister à leur réunion
parce que c'est très intéressant de les
voir réfléchir et c'est très intéressant
de les écouter discuter dialoguer avec
les personnes qu'elles s'additionnent et
nous avons décidé que de la même façon
que législateur a prévu que les réunions
du comité consultatif ne sont pas
publics mais que c'est le fruit de ses
réflexions qui est rendue publique
il n'y avait pas de raison de demander à
cette conférence de citoyens de
fonctionner d'une manière qui nous
paraissait pas la plus souhaitable pour
nous et donc nous avons décidé de les
laisser seuls avec un animateur
simplement pour pas de président de
mateur pour essayer de dénouer les
moments où ils risquent de ne rien se
passer et nous leur avons proposé dix
intervenants
enfin ces quatre week-ends dix
intervenants comment est ce que nous
avons choisi le but était évidemment pas
qu'ils soient objectifs le but était
qu'il reflète au mieux les différents
horizons et les différentes perspectives
qu'on peut avoir sur ces questions de
fin de vie une chose qui a facilité
notre choix c'est que la vie 121 comme
un tiers des avis du cca ne faisait que
les habits du ccn ne sont pas pris à
l'unanimité ce qui a pour effet au cours
de la réflexion de ne pas condamner les
membres à être tous d'accord d'emblée et
donc le risque si on est tous d'accord
c'est d'arriver au plus petit
dénominateur commun que ça soit pas très
intéressant donc chacun participe à la
réflexion mais on sait que si in fine et
un ou des membres pensent qu'il y à une
autre façon de réfléchir ou une autre
façon de poser des questions et bien une
opinion minoritaire est écrite qui est
adjointe à la vie j'ai compté à cette
époque est à peu près un tiers des avis
du ccn depuis sa création qui comporte
une opinion minoritaire qui peut être
signé par une personne qui peut être
anonyme et qui peut compter jusqu'à 15
membres du comité sur 40 mais nous ne
comptons pas donc nous avons un avis
majoritaire
nous ne votons pas sauf eux dans le
passé avant que je ne prenne la
présidence de passer à certains moments
qui était particulièrement difficile
nous considérons qu'il ya une majorité
et puis que ceux qui veulent
éventuellement exprimé une opinion
minoritaire l'expriment il se trouve que
dans la vie 121 il y avait un consensus
sur toute une série de questions qui
concerne l accès aux soins palliatifs
l'accompagnement d'amont là le droit à
une sédation profonde jusqu'au 10 le
fait que les directives anticipées et
s'impose aux soignants mais il y avait
une divergence profonde que nous avons
retrouvé d'ailleurs non pas en termes
statistiques mais en termes
d'argumentation dans la société lorsque
nous devons élaborer notre rapport sur
la question d'euthanasie va si on se
suicide donc l'avis majoritaire
expliquer pour quelles raisons ils
considéraient qu'il n'était pas
souhaitable d'autoriser l'assistance au
suicide et l'euthanasie
tu te dis très simplement c'est le sait
le souci d'aider des personnes les plus
vulnérables et la pignon minoritaires
expliquer pourquoi une autre façon
d'aborder la question permettait
d'envisager l'autorisation et donc nous
avions un rapporteur plutôt deux de
l'avis majoritaire et un rapporteur de
l'avis minoritaire et donc ce que j'ai
fait c'est que les prix le rapporteur de
l'avis majoritaire et le rapporteur de
l'opinion minoritaires et nous avons à
trois choisit des intervenants qui
reflétait non seulement ce qui était
consensuel mais ces visions divergentes
et donc nous avons eu pour dire je parle
de 10,1 mais nous avions jean leonetti
est le président de l'association du
droit pour mourir dans la dignité
donc voilà on a essayé de construire
quelque chose qui soit représentatif des
différentes opinions
nous avons voulu donner une dimension
internationale et donc j'ai demandé à
deux collègues le président du comité
d'éthique d'un pays qui a la même
législation que nous et qui est le
portugal et le président du comité
d'éthique d'un pays qui a une situation
tout à fait différente qui est le
président du comité consultatif national
d'éthique de belgique de faire partir de
ces dix intervenants pour qu' il est non
seulement la diversité des vues mais une
dimension internationale dans leur
réflexion
et puis nous avons fait ce qui se fait
dans d'autres pays c'est pour ne pas
influencer les citoyens nous leur avons
dit qu'une fois qu'il aurait auditionné
ces dix intervenants il pourrait choisir
les dix suivants eux-mêmes et donc ils
ont choisi ils nous ont demandés nous
ont transmis leurs demandes pour
demander à dix intervenants
supplémentaire de venir dialoguer avec
eux donc voyez que le souci c'est de
leur apporter les éléments de la
réflexion mais d'essayer de ne pas les
influencer en n'assistant pas et de en
eux les formant pas trop vient pas
tellement ce mot de formateurs parce que
former s'est déformée c'est sait comment
faire en sorte qu'ils s'approprient eux
mêmes leurs réflexions en cours de route
et puis lorsqu'ils ont donné leur avis
qui est aussi assez rare je crois
d'après ce que j'ai appris nous allons
décider parce que souvent les
conférences de citoyens rendre leur avis
et puis ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs
lors de la révision de la loi de
bioéthique de 2011 ce ne sont pas les
citoyens qui ont fait la conférence de
presse ce sont les organisateurs des
états généraux qui ont dit ce que les
citoyens pensaient donc ce que nous
avons fait c'est que nous avons organisé
une conférence de presse dans laquelle
les citoyens
rendez compte de leurs avis et les
citoyens dialoguer avec les journalistes
donc c'est vraiment un processus
d'appropriation et je crois que ce qui
nous a beaucoup intéressé je dirais
c'est pas tellement l'opinion et la vie
qu'ils ont émis encore que l'originalité
la façon dont ils ont abordé nous a
appris des choses c'est sais je dirais
la la le sérieux avait claqué avec
lequel 18 personnes extrêmement diverses
se connaissant pas s'approprie la
réflexion si on leur donne les moyens
fonde d'avoir véritablement une
influence et une action il ya une espèce
d'intelligence collective qui n'est et
ses citoyens je trouve ça très émouvant
nous ont dit lorsqu'on les a rejoint une
fois qu'ils avaient élaboré leur avis
avant la conférence de presse du
lendemain nous ont dit que ça les avait
profondément marqué qu'ils allaient
continuer à se revoir et ils se sont
revus
ils ont même j'ai appris qu'ils ont
écrit des articles ensemble parce que
c'est une expérience dont ils nous ont
dit pour certains le savent et
transformé leur vie
donc je crois que c'est intéressant et
que c'est pas quelques conférences de
citoyens soit un moyen privilégié qui
débat public mais je crois que ça nous
dit c'est que tous les moyens de débats
publics qui permettent à des personnes
de se réunir dans la diversité et de
croiser leurs regards sont essentiels
indépendamment de tout ce qui peut
exister
je dirais en réunion deux personnes de
même profession de même région et je
crois que c'est ça que ça nous apprend
ces riches et c'est intéressant
donc voilà pour la conférence de
citoyens alors j'étais tellement sûre si
vous me rappelez juste
d'accord lui même professionnel voilà
j'étais tellement sûr d'avoir compris
que j'ai noté quelque chose qui est
ininterprétable voix la voix la décision
d'aujourd'hui
alors je crois bon le le comité là
encore le comité
le comité n'a pas travaillé sur cette
question et l'autorisation qui a été
donnée d'après ce que j'ai appris par l'
agence de la biomédecine aujourd'hui je
dirais tu indépendante pour l'instant
d'un travail du comité le comité a rendu
un certain nombre d'avis sur la question
des greffes d'organes depuis 31 ans est
le dernier avis veut croire au montât à
trois ans mais il n'y a pas eu de
travail spécifique sur cette question je
pense qu'elle mérite là aussi mais vous
voyez quand je là encore après il ya une
question de priorités de temps et de
possibilités c'est une question qui
mérite d'être posée pourquoi parce que à
mon sens les questions qui se posent
il y en a deux l'une c'est le croisement
entre la loi sur la fin de vie et la
question du don d'organes c'est à dire
si on ne pas arriver un paradoxe ou au
fond la seule raison pour laquelle on
maintiendra en vie une personne que les
traitements ne peuvent pas sauver ce que
la loi du du 22 avril appelle de
l'obstination déraisonnable serait faite
parce que la justification de
l'obstination déraisonnable
ça serait d'aider autrui et donc comment
est ce qu'on peut penser alors peut-être
que dans le cas d'un consentement
peut-être dans le cadre de directives
anticipées
mais est ce qu'on peut en dehors de
directives anticipées et en dehors d'une
expression d'un souhait croiser de
manière arbitraire
ces deux approches contradictoires donc
ça me paraît une question importante
notre concerne la question
une question à titre personnel qui me
préoccupe depuis un certain temps et qui
est le fait que nous accordons en
matière de alors des gens parlent de
dons d'organes
une personne qui n'est pas consciente
voir qui est morte cérébralement à ma
connaissance ne donne rien pour donner
il faut veut pouvoir le dire
et donc lorsqu'on parle de dons
d'organes chez des personnes en état de
mort cérébrale c'est assez étrange c'est
comme si la personne se réveillait
disait je donne c'est un prélèvement
alors non pas sauf et c'est là que c'est
intéressant c'est que en france vous
avez le droit de dire non il ya un
registre dunant et à ce moment on ne
demande à personne je vais vous n'avez
pas le droit de dire oui et d'empreintes
si vous avez une carte de donneur ce que
beaucoup de gens ont
elle n'a pas de valeur légale et qu'est
ce qu'on va faire on va demander à la
famille si la famille pense que vous ne
vous opposiez pain et donc je crois que
le fait qu'ils aient pas de registre du
oui complique encore cette question vous
voulez poser parce qu'on peut avoir dit
oui avant et pour moi ça existe dans
certains pays il ya toujours une peur
des donneurs d'organes que si on demande
aux gens de dire oui diront pas oui on
peut dire oui on peut dire non et on
peut ne rien dire et si on ne dit rien
il revient à ce moment à la famille ce
qui est un moment très douloureux qui
explique sans doute le nombre de refus
croissant actuellement lorsqu'on demande
aux familles c'est à dire juin mais
elles disent je ne pense pas que la
personne voulait parce que c'est un peu
bizarre lorsque vous ne dites pas la
personne peut dire oui avant mais on va
demander à la famille si par hasard et
la famille dit si on l'a pas demandé à
la personne pourquoi est ce qu'on nous
demande à nous donc je crois que on peut
dire oui on peut dire non et si on n'a
rien dit à ce moment on laisse à la
famille le soin de dire ce qu'elle pense
que la personne voulait donc je pense
que ces sujets se croiser
je pense ça pose un certain nombre de
questions je ne peux vous communiquer
que mon questionnement personnel mais je
pense que ça mérite une réflexion sous
une forme ou une autre du comité
consultatif national d'éthique alors la
disparité des législations c'est un peu
ce que j'évoquais ce que nous faisons
pour l'instant ce que je souhaite c'est
que nous réfléchissions ensemble entre
comité de pays différents qui sont pas
d'ailleurs forcément en phase avec la
loi
c'est pas parce qu'un comité
et dans un pays dont la législation est
telle que le comité ne questionne pas
cette hésitation mais il a l'expérience
de cette pratique que nous voyons du
dehors et que que les membres du comité
vous voit de l'intérieur et donc
j'aimerais bien que nous réfléchissions
ensemble y compris je dirais dans une
vision altruiste ma première
préoccupation c est ce qu un pays qui
par exemple prenons l'angleterre
autorise aviation pour autrui sous
certaines conditions
considérera que le fait que nous
n'autorisons pas passer notre problème
et c'est pas à eux de réfléchir pour
nous aider à penser donc la première ma
première question c'est ce que nous
pouvons réfléchir ensemble d'une manière
altruiste c'est à dire au fond nous
préoccuper du questionnement des autres
même si le problème ne se pose pas dans
le pays que ce soit dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
est ce que nous pouvons aider ceux qui
ceux qui prélève le sang en rémunérant à
réfléchir en nous mettant à leur place
et en les aidant
donc ça c'est ce que je souhaite pour
l'instant c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe pour l'instant ce qui se passe
c'est que nous bénéficions de la
réflexion de nos collègues pour
approfondir la nôtre
et ce qui est intéressant c'est pas
tellement que dans un pays ont dit oui
et dans un autre pays on dîne en c2 quel
point on part pour arriver à cette
conclusion skis presse russe qui
enrichit énormément la réflexion c'est
de voir qu'il ya plusieurs façon de
poser le problème
indépendamment de la de la conclusion
qu'on en tire est donc ces différentes
façons de poser le problème même si elle
ne change rien aux conclusions ou à une
réflexion je dirais nous enrichissent
c'est à dire qu'au fond nous
réfléchissons nous réfléchissons dans
une meilleure connaissance des causes
que si nous étions seuls à nous poser la
question que j'ai trouvé dans beaucoup
de domaines qu'il s'agisse la fin de vie
du début de vie de beaucoup d'autres
questions
les conclusions qui nous qui peuvent
nous paraître étrange ne sont pas des
coups de dés 1 cl
elle procède d'un tas d'une réflexion
d'une façon de poser les questions de
présupposés qu'on peut d'ailleurs
ensuite discuté qui sont différents des
nôtres et donc c'est ça c'est ça qui
nous enrichit je dirais depuis depuis
longtemps mais ce que je souhaiterais
maintenant c'est que nous réfléchissions
ensemble à nos problèmes respectifs
il me reste deux questionneur mais je
voudrais juste vous dire à vendre sur
officer que dans le cadre du don
d'organes que rares étaient ou en état
de mort cérébrale le sénat à l'époque
dans le cas de la der des lois de
bioéthique avait voté un article
autorisant ce prélèvement
même sans le wii et que cet article a
été supprimée par la somalisation de
lens 8
je passe la parole à madame visite chez
vie merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur mécène vous avez présidé le
comité éthique et scientifique de la
fondation internationale de la recherche
appliquée sur le handicap
en même temps je pense sur les enfants
handicapés et je voulais savoir à peu
près si vous pouviez mais en dire
davantage
on use mission sachant quand même que
tous les angles et entre 800 et 900
enfants qui naissent en france
otis on décèle l'autisme peu de temps
après et surtout on nous dit que nos
gros 70 à 80 % de garçons parmi ces
outils
merci monsieur amiel wilma questions
posées se porter sur la fin de vie et
sur les limites entre l'égalisation et
dépénalisation de l'euthanasie un jeu
prenant carrément le mot alors deux
choses vous avez parlé de des
conférences des conférences de citoyens
qui intègre enfin qui répondent en
partie à la question je voulais poser
sur la participation de non expert en la
matière parce qu'au fond c'est quelque
chose qui concerne au fonds viennent
tout le monde et dont les décisions sont
prises par des experts qui relève du
médical du juridique ou du philosophique
mais la question de dépénaliser ou de
légiférer peut peut-être se poser sur
les des questions de fin de vie parce
que quelque chose que l'on aborde
rarement c'est que les avis qui seront
donnés excusez moi je mets un peu les
pieds dans le plat mais sans donner par
des gens bien portants
moi je vous fais évidemment je vous fais
part de 35 ans d'exercice de la médecine
la demande d'euthanasie active est
rarissime
moi ça m'est arrivé trois fois en 35 ans
et j'ai accompagné de très très nombreux
patients en fin de vie et je m'aperçois
que l'état d'esprit que l'on peut avoir
quand on est disons le au bord du
gouffre n'est pas forcément du tout le
même que celui que l'on avait la même
personne
vingt ans avant en pleine forme et ça
j'ai rarement vu cette cet aspect abordé
dans les différentes personnes
associations groupes qui qui aborde
cette question là et ça me paraît
pourtant tout à fait crucial
lorsqu'on est au bord de la fin de vie
on n'a pas forcément envie de demander
ce qu'on demandait 20 ans avant je me
rappelle d'un débat qui est complètement
dépassée c'était de béton dire la vérité
aux patients vous rappeler c'était avec
léon schwartzenberg
ça remonte à un paquet d'années
maintenant c'est complètement dépassés
ce débat là mais on sait que à l'époque
c'était le directeur du monde qui
pourtant participé du même ouvrage à
s'était fâché lorsqu'on lui avait dit
lorsque le le cancérologue lui avait dit
la vérité là c'est un petit peu la même
chose
donc ça rejoint la deuxième question je
voulais poser y at-il lieu de légiférer
absolument plutôt que deux dépénaliser
et finalement c'est c'est la fin de la
question et c'est pas du tout la même
chose alors je ne crois pas que ce soit
la fin de la question je vous donne un
exemple la suisse est la suisse a
dépénalisé l'assistance au suicide
l'euthanasie est interdite donc je veux
dire la dépénalisation peut être aussi
sélectif que l'autorisation je crois
qu'elle dit autre chose
ce n'est pas la même chose d'un point de
vue symbolique de dépénaliser ou
d'autoriser
mais ce n'est pas parce que ce n'est pas
la même chose d'un point de vue
symbolique que ce n'est pas aussi
sélectif
donc je crois que c'est c'est une c'est
une autre question complémentaire et on
voit que certains pays ont autorisé
l'assistance au suicide ou l'euthanasie
d'autres l'ont dépénaliser mais que
c'est très sélectif et c'est étrangement
sélectif si on se place dans un contexte
international puisque la suisse a
dépénalisé l'assistance au suicide n'est
interdit pénalement l'euthanasie la
belgique autorise l'euthanasie n'est
interdit l'assistance au suicide
donc c'est l'image en miroir de la
suisse pourquoi la hollande autorise
l'euthanasie et l'assistance au suicide
c'est d'ailleurs le seul pays qui
autorisent les deux avec le luxembourg
l'état d'oregon l'état de washington
l'état du vermont et l'état du montana
aux états unis ont autorisé l'assistance
au suicide et interdisent l'euthanasie
donc on voit que même l'avancé dans ces
questions là pour des raisons qui sont
des raisons d' approche de réflexion de
culture d'histoire n'est pas du tout
évidente et on n'est pas du tout dans
dans du tout rien on est dans dans dans
des raisonnements qui prenne en compte
la question d'autonomie
la question de la solidarité de la
question du rôle de la médecine dans un
pays comme la hollande
l'assistance au suicide et l'euthanasie
sont la sphère du médecin en suisse
c'est ou dans les états n'est qu'à
celles affaire d'association et pas des
médecins vous voyez qu'il ya des tas de
questions que ça pose ce que vous disiez
qui est très important nous le
mentionnons en conclut un peu avant la
conclusion de notre rapport nous disons
que les divergences nous nous trouvons
et nous dit on dans ce rapport qu'il ya
il ya toute une série de deux approches
convergent dans le débat en particulier
un constat accablant
je vous rappelle que ce que nous
retenons du débat c'est que 80% de nos
concitoyens non pas que c'est au
soulagement de leurs douleurs leurs
souffrances et un accompagnement
humains en fin de vie bien que la loi du
9 juin 1999 donne ce droit à tous depuis
15 ans donc il ya quelque chose que nous
considérons comme dont nous avons dit
que c'est un scandale il ya toute une
série de réflexions qui sont tout à fait
convergentes et si je devais le résumé
je pense intéressant dans nous pensons
et nous avons et nous avons écrit que la
loi santé et la loi adaptation du pays
au vieillissement est sans doute un des
moyens de réussir à pallier à ce défaut
flagrant pourquoi parce que nous pensons
que si on n'arrive pas à accompagner les
personnes en toute fin de vie c'est
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à les
accompagner avant et que donc si on
n'arrive pas à les accompagner avant il
n'est pas étonnant que dans les trois
dernières semaines
on ne trouve pas un moyen miracle pour
le faire et donc nous pensons que c'est
une question d' accompagnement des
personnes âgées malades handicapés
longtemps avant leur fin qui permettrait
d'inscrire le soin le soulagement de la
douleur le soulagement des souffrances
dans une pratique devenue je dirais
habituelles y compris dans les phases
extrême de la fin de vie deux demandes
convergentes le droit à pouvoir dormir
jusqu'au lycée si on le demande que ça
ne soit pas le médecin qui décide c'est
qu'il ya un paradoxe dans la loi du 22
avril 2005
si la personne est inconsciente le
médecin est obligé de faire une sédation
profonde jusqu'au décès parce qu'on ne
sait pas si la personne pourrait
souffrir si la personne est consciente
c'est le médecin qui décide et donc
l'idée c'est que si la personne le
demande
et bien que ça devienne un droit c'est
ce que nous avons perçu la deuxième
c'est les directives anticipées que les
directives anticipées s'impose
sauf si le médecin a de bonnes raisons
de penser qu'elles ne correspondent pas
à l'état de la personne et donc il
faudrait pas répliqué en ce qui concerne
encore une fois l'euthanasie
l'assistance au suicide divergences au
sein du comité consultatif et
divergences dans la société y compris
sur la terminologie ce qui nous a
beaucoup frappé pour la conférence de
citoyens
contrairement à la commission si car
contrairement au ccn de l'euthanasie
c'est de l'assistance au suicide
ce que dit la conférence du citoyen
c'est ce qui compte c'est l'autonomie de
la personne et donc qu'on me donne les
moyens d' interrompre ma vie ou que
quelqu'un le fasse à ma demande
c'est la même chose pour d'autres comme
la commission si car il ya une
différence radicale entre donner les
moyens à quelqu'un de faire quelque
chose et le faire directement d'envoyer
que même sur la terminologie quelle est
la différence
qu'est ce qui est en jeu il n'y a pas
vraiment raccord est ce que nous
écrivons un peu avant la fin c'est que
il nous semble qu'une partie de ces
divergences vient non seulement de deux
points de départ de perspective
philosophique éthique culturelle
différente chez les personnes mais
qu'elle vient des différents points
d'où les personnes parlent et donc le
disons que lorsqu'on parle de fin de vie
je crois que nous avons été tué ce
chapitre 2 qui parlons nous quand nous
parlons de la fin de vie on parle de la
fin de vie de personne quand on est bien
portant on parle de la vie de la fin de
vie de soi quand on est bien portant on
parle de la fin de vie de soi quand on
est malade on parle de 2 2 tonnes de sa
propre femme fille quand on va très mal
on parle de la fin de vie de proches on
parle de la fin de vie de personnes
qu'on ne connaît pas on parle de la fin
de vie de personnes qu'on peut assister
si on y soigne en août et donc tout
c'est au fond c'est un sujet et c'est
une question éthique très particulière
parce que contrairement à beaucoup de
questions d'éthique à nous concerne tous
quand on parle d'assistance médicale à
la procréation ça concerne certains
d'entre nous donc est ce que ça concerne
et il ya les autres
la fin de vie nous concerne tous mais
elle nous concerne à différents moments
de la vie à des titres très différents
et donc cette espèce de je dirais de
confusion implicite fait que certaines
positions s'opposent
parce qu'on ne parle pas de la fin de
vie des mêmes personnes où on ne parle
pas de sa fin de vie au même ça donc
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
importance que ce que ce que vous ce que
vous mentionnez et qui nous a paru un
des points je dirais qui n'a pas été
questionné ou qui a très peu été
questionnée durant le débat et c'est
pour ça que nous soulevons puisqu'il ya
toute une partie de notre rapport que
nous consacrons à essayer de dégager les
questions que nous considérons comme
sous jacente est implicite et dont nous
pensons que la formulation aiderait à
clarifier un certain nombre de points
dans le débat sur ce que vous dites
aussi tout autre chose
il ya un article qui m'avait beaucoup
frappé qui a été fait par steven laureys
ce qui est le directeur du centre du
coma du coma center de liège celui où
vincent lambert avait été examinée au
départ car des deux plus grands centres
du monde d'études des personnes qui ne
sont pas capables de communiquer en état
de conscience minimale
cet article avait été publié en 2011
dans un journal médical tournoi et c'est
une étude très particulière 2700
soignants de l'ensemble des pays du
conseil de l'europe avait reçu un
questionnaire dans ce questionnaire des
pleins de questions
au début les questions concernaient le
fait de savoir si ces soignants si ces
professionnels de santé est ce que si
l'un de leurs patients étaient en état
de conscience minimale
il considérait qu'il fallait arrêter les
traitements l'hydratation la nutrition
artificielle 70% des soignants dizaine
ont beaucoup plus loin dans le
questionnaire il y avait une question
qui disait si vous étiez dans un état de
conscience minimale est ce que vous
souhaiteriez que on interrompre les
traitements hydratation entre
scientifiques seuls 70% des soignants
répondait oui
et l'éditorial de steven laureys c'était
que c'est quand même un problème éthique
si des soignants n'arrive pas ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure soi même comme
un autre aaa a essayé de se mettre à la
place des autres et de réfléchir en
prenant les devants content d'envoyer
comme c'est difficile y compris pour des
soignants qui voient leurs vins de vie
et la fin de vie de leurs patients d'une
manière radicalement différente je crois
que se mettre ensemble ce que je disais
pour pouvoir réfléchir ensemble en
partant de points de vue différents mais
qui sont exclus
cité faciliterait sans doute
l'avancement de ceux de ce débat sur la
fin de vie voilà pour cette audition de
jean claude ameisen médecin également
président du comité consultatif national
d'éthique il a été auditionné car
candidat à sa reconduction candidats en
tout cas du président de la république
rappelons que ce comité a pour mission
d'émettre des avis sur des questions de
société des problèmes éthiques suscitées
par les progrès de la science de la
médecine des avis auxquels son est très
souvent remis françois hollande
dernièrement rappelons que lors de sa
dernière renouvellement ce comité a
suscité de nombreux débats notamment
parce que de nombreuses personnalités de
gauche ont été nommés à cette occasion
en 2012 enfin on peut dire que ce comité
aura pour mission au printemps 2015 de
remettre un avis sur un sujet
extrêmement polémique extrêmement
débattu celui de l'ouverture de la
procréation médicalement assistée aux
célibataires mais aussi aux couples
homosexuels une promesse il faut dire
une promesse de campagne de françois
hollande
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
ce soir